evalúe 1 por x cuando x es igual a menos
1 x es igual a 0 y x es igual a 1 vamos
a ver el primer caso cuando x es igual a
menos 1
hay dos formas de pensar en ello
sustituimos esto en la ecuación y nos
queda que es 1 por x que es igual a
menos 1 por lo que va a ser 1 x menos 1
hay dos formas de pensar en ello uno por
cualquier cosa es esa cosa por lo que
uno por menos uno va a ser igual a menos
uno otra forma de verlo es tomar el
valor absoluto de ambos números uno por
uno el valor absoluto de menos uno es
uno el resultado va a ser igual a uno y
como tienen diferentes signo el
resultado va a ser negativo al final
tendremos exactamente la misma respuesta
ahora hagamos para el caso en el que x
va a ser igual a cero
x
a 0 lo sustituimos en esta expresión 1
por x es 0 entonces 1 por 0
y aquí también tenemos dos formas de ver
esto nuevamente el 1 por cualquier cosa
va a ser igual a cualquier cosa así que
uno por cero va a ser igual a cero otra
forma de verlo es que cualquier cosa
multiplicada por cero va a ser igual a
cero y en cualquiera de estas opciones
nos va a dar el mismo resultado cero
vamos a escribir esto de este otro lado
lo que les acabo de mencionar para
recordarlo
cualquier cosa
x cualquier cosa va a ser igual a esta
cosa por la que fue multiplicado el 1 y
que 0 por cualquier cosa siempre va a
ser igual a cero así que tenemos estas
dos formas de ver finalmente el tercer
caso cuando x es igual a 1 lo
sustituimos en la expresión uno por uno
pues ya sabemos la respuesta cualquier
cosa multiplicada por uno va a ser igual
a cualquier otra cosa en este caso es a
cualquier otra cosa es uno por lo que
nuestro resultado va a ser igual a uno